the jurogan experience
one of the things that happened to me um
as a result of like
traveling all over the world is that i
met this
schizophrenia researcher um his name is
paul fletcher he's at
cambridge um and he wanted to
experience like schizophrenia he's
treating these people
and he wanted to really know because of
this critique that you just
laid out um he's the only
person who i know in that area who's
done this you know so he
he did like ketamine to try and
reproduce the experience because he
heard that that was like reproducing the
would reproduce experience
of course it doesn't but this is what
people have said
our animal models use ketamine for that
reason but it doesn't
but he was curious enough to try to
figure out what schizophrenic people who
are diagnosed with schizophrenia
he tried to figure out what they were
experiencing
um i don't know if he figured
that out from this sort of experiential
perspective
but what i do know is that if i ever had
a relative
who had schizophrenia i would send them
to paul fletcher
um because his perspective on it
i it really respects the person who
has this diagnosis and um
it offers them the greatest amount of
hope
that i have seen in that area and
it would be good if other scientists
in these areas drugs whatever it is
would also seek to try to figure out the
experience
that their paper their patients are
going through
yeah it'd be almost like learning
martial arts without ever sparring
yeah yeah yeah or you know
coaching basketball without yeah
whatever playing yeah
yeah under pressure do you is there
anything that mimics
schizophrenia that that someone is there
like a commonly
thought of substance that mimics
schizophrenia
um they have
suggested large doses of amphetamines
over periods of time with sleep
deprivation
can mimic paranoid schizophrenia but i
don't know if it really does i mean
all of this stuff i am now questioning
so i don't know i mean at one time if
you would ask me that question maybe
five years ago i would have said
amphetamines but i don't know now
schizophrenia is an odd one too right
because doesn't it affect somewhere in
the neighborhood of one percent of the
population
yeah that's a lot of people it's a lot
of people um
uh but i have a lot more hope about
schizophrenia after having met paul
fletcher
just in terms of um
i i don't want to bastardize his sort of
model of thinking about it and so
i may not have all the details right but
i would just say
just simply try and explain about like
you and i
we go through the world everybody we
have these theories about how the world
works
like um like you smile i
have a theory about what that means
right and so
uh oh joe likes me or he's happy today
whatever
and then i'm right because you tell me
that whatever
somebody who's diagnosed with
schizophrenia they also have these
models that they're testing out
and so their model might be like uh
you when you smile they think that
you're angry or whatever
uh and you're plotting against them yes
and
their motto is just wrong i mean it's
just like they're just getting
they just have uh they're bumping uh
bumping up against
uh these wrong answers and then when
they get they get more
wrong answers it's even it causes even
more stress
and that's very anxiety provoking and
then all of that is playing
into this it's like first of all your
models are off
and now you're just getting this
increased anxiety and so
i think that's how his model sees it so
that that means that
it's okay as long as we let people
understand that don't worry if your
model
is getting it wrong it doesn't mean that
that something's wrong with you it could
be
maybe we are get we have it wrong
in our society and you have you might
have a better way
of thinking about this so it's like as
opposed to it being
one way there might be multiple ways of
thinking about these
these solving these problems that humans
saw throughout their day
and that's how i think that's how he
thinks of
it um and it's a it's a
it's a model of hope for me because
um you lessen the anxiety among the
patients
and many of the much of the problems
deals with this anxiety of people
telling them that they're
incompetent and you know how that is how
that feels as an adult somebody telling
you that you're incompetent
it's like how can you tell me i'm i'm
incompetent so it exacerbates whatever
problems
exactly i initially have it makes them
far worse exactly yeah there's also a
thing that seems to have i've only known
a few people that are schizophrenic but
it's it's a disturbing thing when they
think that everybody's against them
and they feel like they're on their own
but by virtue of everyone being
against them they feel they feel
isolated yes and then
their whatever paranoia they have it's
like throwing
dry sticks on it just rages into a fire
and it gets even worse because they
think that people are plotting against
them and everyone's against them and
they don't have anybody comforting them
yes and we need that we all need that
absolutely you know and
i think particularly people with like a
slippery version of reality
probably need that more than most yeah
when you say reality
um it might be multiple realities
and that's the thing that we need people
to understand
or that it's like it's okay um
it might be your reality just might be
different from theirs
but not to the point where you have a
different reality and that you're
allowed to abuse people
not so i want to be clear because i know
there are some people out here
saying something about alternative facts
not i don't mean it like where you
manipulate people i mean it for people
who are struggling
uh like these people with schizophrenia
um
just to help lessen their anxiety yeah
so
with in terms of marijuana particularly
like high doses of marijuana
um particularly edible marijuana could
really
seriously exacerbate someone who has
who's
kind of hanging on barely anyway and
then boom you eat an edible
absolutely you're [ __ ] so someone like
alex would say
that person schizophrenia was brought on
by marijuana
whereas i think you and i would probably
agree they were more
likely inclined towards schizophrenia
anyway
and the high dose of marijuana pushed
them over there and then you know
everything
all the evidence says what you just said
i mean so when you look at the evidence
where people have done
all of these studies um folks who didn't
have these predispositions
um marijuana then
doesn't cause people to be schizophrenic
or have a psychotic disorder right
but it certainly can precipitate
um or exacerbate um
um um psychosis in people who are
pre-expressed
predisposed so what i was going to get
to was do you think that maybe for
people
that have this predisposition
towards schizophrenia they should
probably avoid
psychoactive substances or avoid
something that radically
perturbs their version of reality
they probably should avoid cannabis
right
um i don't want to say avoid everything
because
um is there anything
yeah i mean so like they could maybe use
that maybe would help them yeah so i
spent a little time working in a heroin
clinic
in geneva and so they give out heroin to
these patients twice a day every day
intravenous or oral however the patient
wants it
but a lot of intravenous heroin users
and it's all you know sanitized setting
hospital setting or clinic setting twice
a day
many of these people have
psychotic disorders like diagnosed with
schizophrenia and heroin
helps mediation yeah with many of these
symptoms and they feel better
even more so in some cases than
antipsychotic
uh really yeah i talk about this in the
new book in fact but yeah this is
uh so i don't want to have this blanket
statement that they should avoid
psychoactive substances because some
might actually be
helpful and
some other people have tried other drugs
one psychiatrist in the netherlands
gave his patients amphetamines and he
swears that it works but that has to be
researched out but we'll see
but i know cannabis for sure uh
i i wouldn't do that one you wouldn't do
cannabis and perhaps maybe not
high levels of amphetamines as well
either right because i i don't know
you know i i will i would have to um
um slowly titrate and see whether or not
it worked or whether or not people felt
better
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience